Schritt für Schritt auf eng vermessenen
Bahnen Zentimeter für Zentimeter voran
bis der Metalldetektor anschlägt fährt
man nie ist auf was gestoßen das
Bruchstück einer Fliegerbombe
das hier ist natürlich nicht mehr
gefährlich aber wir wissen eben nie was
wir als nächstes finden
14 Hektar ist das Gebiet groß ein
Drittel haben sie schon abgesucht zwei
fehlen noch da ist noch viel zu tun da
kann noch viel passieren
ja ich habe Angst jeder Schritt ist
gefährlich aber wir haben unsere
Sicherheitsregeln an die wir uns ganz
genau halten und wenn wir das tun müsste
alles okay sein
müsste also kein Risiko keine
Nachlässigkeit Pausen ein Aufmerksamkeit
hochhalten das hier soll Ackerland
werden aber bevor die Bauern kommen
müssen Sie sicher sein dass es sicher
ist
jeder Fund wird vom sektionskommandeur
nachgeprüft und der sektionskommandeur
ist fettmannis mann
ich mache mir Sorgen um meine Frau aber
sie ist gut ausgebildet weiß was sie tun
muss nur generell ist es schon schwierig
wenn ausgerechnet ein paar diesen Job
macht es ist ja für uns beide gefährlich
der Einsatzleiter der Hilfsorganisation
handicap International erinnert seine
Leute immer wieder daran sie verdienen
gutes Geld weit über Durchschnitt und
die Arbeit geht nicht aus aber das ist
nichts vorüber sie sich freuen
es ist traurig zu sehen dass heute in
anderen Ländern gekämpft und bombardiert
wird in der Ukraine etwa was ist dort
mit den Zivilisten
wir hier in Laos leiden unter einem
Krieg der zig Jahre hinter uns liegt und
es ist immer noch lebensgefährlich so
etwas blüht den Menschen in
Kriegsgebieten anderswo jetzt auch
der indoch China Krieg tobte nicht nur
in Vietnam auch in Laos auch dort
standen sich kommunistische Truppen und
die von den USA unterstützte Armee
gegenüber zwischen 1963 und 74 werfen
die Amerikaner mehr als zwei Millionen
Tonnen Munition über dem Land ab
Brandbomben Streubomben dazu Minen
Granaten eine riesige Fläche jedes
vierte Dorf des Landes gilt als mit
Blindgängern verseucht die sie heute
suchen und jeden Tag finden markiert und
mit einem Sand sagt gesichert Streu
Munition nicht explodiert wer drauf
tritt löst sie aus oder jetzt darf sie
frei liegt reicht schon Hitze durch
Sonneneinfall
wenn wir eine gefunden haben wissen wir
dass da noch mehr sind ein abgeworfener
bombencontainer enthält 600 bis 700
Sprengsätze
und das Gelände ist hügelig wenn die
Abwurfhöhe nicht groß genug war dann
explodiert die Munition nicht wir
schätzen das etwa 30 Prozent beim Abwurf
nicht hochgegangen sind und noch hier
liegen
sie sind Experten Sie wissen wann ein
Geschoss angefasst werden darf und wann
nicht diese Granate kommt in ein Erdloch
um die Splitter zu minimieren die bei
der Sprengung hochfetzen denn
entschärfen heißt hier immer sprengen
aber erst wenn alle im Umkreis
vorgewarnt und in Sicherheit sind
[Musik]
ein solcher rumps hat chipos Leben
verändert er war 17 als er seinen halben
Arm verlor jedes Jahr erwischt es
dutzende Bauern die Graben Kinder die
spielen sie verlieren Arme Beine manche
ihr lebt
wir haben ein Spiel gespielt und dabei
ist mein Ball verschwunden er ist in den
Büschen gelandet den Ball habe ich dort
nicht gefunden aber etwas anderes rundes
aus Metall und ich dachte damit kann ich
auch spielen
sagt er habe lange an Selbstmord gedacht
glaubte nie eine Frau zu finden eine
Familie zu haben die Hochzeit die vier
Kinder das ist das große Glück aber für
die Eltern auch Sorge
haben immer Angst um die Kinder ich sage
ihnen dass sie ganz vorsichtig sein
müssen beim Spielen nichts anfassen
seht euch euren Vater an erst ein warnen
des Beispiel für euch
das Leben mit einem Arm läuft holprig
aber Jeep pur meistertes
Laos gehört zu den am wenigsten
entwickelten Ländern der Welt vor allem
hier in den Bergen bleibt nicht viel von
dem man leben kann außer Landwirtschaft
chipor spricht von Glück weil er
wenigstens noch einen gesunden Arm hat
so könne er für seine Familie sorgen
manche Gedanken jedoch muss auch er wohl
verdrängen
ich habe schon Angst aber das fällt hier
hat schon ein anderer Bauer vor mir
bearbeitet ihm ist nie etwas passiert
also gehe ich davon aus dass es sicher
ist und dass hier keine unexplodierten
Sprengsätze im Boden liegen
des Land mit Menschen die gegen ein
Trauma an leben oder wie das Minensucher
Ehepaar fährt man nie und wanna Wong
versuchen es aus dem Weg zu räumen
Feierabend zu Hause mit Tochter kam
es gibt froh die köstliche Schafe Suppe
und es fällt was ab
wir sind zu Hause wir sind in Sicherheit
allen geht's gut wir spüren die
Erleichterung
aber morgen ist ein neuer Tag dann gehen
wir da wieder raus aufs Feld dann wird
es wieder gefährlich das ist unser Job
fast 50 Jahre ist der Krieg vorbei und
ist es eben doch nicht bis heute bleibt
das Leben in diesem gezeichneten Land
lebensgefährlich